it's a basic
human need we all want to feel
like we belong this is what a tribe
means
the company has become the modern day
tribe but we don't always feel like we
belong
at work i learn my best lessons by
looking at extreme cases it's why i like
the military because
the stakes are life and death all of the
lessons are easy to see
so what's an extreme version of tribe
the grateful dead
deadheads and you know who's an amazing
person to talk about it
social psychologist and award-winning
harvard professor
amy cuddy i didn't even know she was a
deadhead
but she's followed them for years so we
got together
and talked about what it means to feel
like we belong
this is a bit of optimism
[Music]
thanks for doing this thanks for having
me oh it's my pleasure it's nice to see
you
you too the thing that i wanted to talk
to you about is a topic you and i have
never talked about and i think a lot of
people don't
actually know about you which is you are
a deadhead
i am the deadhead a very proud deadhead
as you can see here
and looks like you have grateful dead
jewelry on me also i do
and you did that deadhead thing where
you traveled the country
going from concert to concert i did they
call it getting on the bus
you know i got on the bus in 1988 in
high school
and then you know when i went to college
i started to
really follow them i mean you'd say
you're going on tour with the dead
so you follow them and go to 12 or 15
consecutive shows
and sleep in parking lots or rest areas
and
you know make friends along the way so
yeah i've been doing that for a long
time and and now that they are
playing again as dead in company with
john mayer who's remarkably
great at filling jerry garcia's shoes
i'm doing that again
the thing that i find so interesting is
you know it's no longer about the music
there are plenty of people who are fans
of an artist
who don't get on the bus who don't
follow them on tour
maybe a couple of cities but not 12 13
14 in a row
and yet you know fish fans do this
grateful dead fans do this what is it
about the grateful dead that makes
people
do this like i said it's only a
partially the music it is partially the
music but let me talk just briefly about
why
the music invites that as well the music
invites that because you know the dead
have played thousands of shows but
they've never played the same show
twice i mean literally they've never
played the same set list
twice so every single show from their
catalog of about 500
songs is a unique combination of those
songs it's two sets
it's about three hours long you know
with a set break in the middle
that means you're getting three hours of
music that no one has ever seen before
and will never see again at every single
show and that is in a way
an incredible act of generosity the fans
feel
that they're putting that much into it
we're gonna give you something brand new
every time but that's not a reason to
travel around the country
yeah that's not enough but that's not
the beginning of what i call
bountious presence and the idea is that
the band is present with each other that
requires them to be able to
hear each other to respond to each other
to lead and to follow
and that presence is sort of contagious
the audience feels that connection
they're in the moment
they're present with each other there's
a kind of
contract that you make an implicit
contract as a deadhead
but that's all after the take me back
like so you go on your first one
and you don't expect to become a groupie
you don't expect to go on tour with them
right
right and if somebody said to you you
know they play a different set list
every time you're not going gonna be
like oh well then let's definitely go do
this
tell me what your experience was the
first concert or two
that made you that sucked you into this
to this community at least
i'm gonna start with a lyric that
explains it and i'll unpack that
one of the more famous grateful dead
lyrics is strangers stopping strangers
just to shake their hand
and you know that might seem oh that's a
nice idea but
that is what it is we are strangers and
at the same time
we are a kind of community but those
friends that i make who i think of as
tour friends i may never see again
but i know that we have agreed to be
kind to each other
in that moment the name of the band the
grateful dead is so scary to parents
it sounds so sinister but the truth is
that what the grateful dead
means it's based on this folk tale where
as jerry garcia would have described it
a wanderer who gives his last penny to
pay for the corpses burial
is then magically aided by the spirit of
the dead person
so the grateful dead is the spirit of
the dead person who was a stranger
wandering through a town
when he or she died a stranger paid for
that person's burial
and now the spirit of that person is
watching over them that is the strangers
stopping strangers just to shake their
hand right so
i think that that philosophy of taking
care of each other even if you don't
know
who someone is and what their past is
what tribe they belong to
that's what it's about and you feel that
immediately
when you're traveling with these fans
who look so
sort of raggedy people in the towns that
you travel to expect
to have this experience that's kind of
scary and they end up
shocked by how friendly the deadheads
were you know if i'm at a dead show
and people who work at the stadium are
coming around picking up trash
every deadhead around that person is
going to help them pick up trash
you know the people in the hotels who
work at the hotels are shocked by how
friendly the deadheads are
the idea is that yes you're traveling
with this community
but wherever you are the people in that
fixed community are now also part of
your community
and you're all going to take care of
each other it's funny the parents hear
the word dead and freak out but the
deadheads actually hear the word
grateful
and that's what brings it's the
gratitude exactly right it's the
gratitude that holds them together
exactly right
so it's a full-on subculture that has
its own rules and norms it has its own
language
like a good subculture does so because
your values fit the values of the dead
of that subculture you find yourself
wanting to spend more time with them
and you know you and i both do work on
subcultures
and there's a feeling of belonging we
all every single one of us seeks
belonging
and we're different and feel like we
don't belong in regular society
and we find a group that accepts us and
we feel like we're there it builds our
self-confidence and it makes us want to
do crazy things like travel around the
country simply to be in the community
and the music becomes the mechanism so
can you tell me
some of the values gratitude clearly is
the one
but can you tell me sort of some of the
values that make you feel
like you belong that you quote unquote
found your people when you go on tour
right there is an extreme kind of
generosity
if you have more and someone else needs
that you give it to them
no questions asked so for example people
in the dead community
don't sell tickets for over face value
or
they'll just give them away so one of
the things that happens at dead shows is
that some people will be walking around
with their fingers up in the air
and saying i need a miracle and what
that means is i need a free ticket
and you trust that those people who are
looking for free tickets
can't afford tickets right not that
they're trying to pull one
over on you and so you give away a
ticket if you have an extra
ticket i received miracles you know when
i was
17 and 18 and i've given out miracles as
a proper adult
so that idea that it's an abundance
mentality
as opposed to a scarcity mentality
people do not have a zero-sum mindset
about anything in the dead community
the idea is that there's enough for
everyone and we just have to figure out
a way
to share it even if it's with a stranger
can you tell if someone's a dead head
when you just meet them in normal
society
um are there clues i mean there are you
know
there are explicit clues i mean apart
from the tie-dye t-shirt
um it somehow manages to work
its way into the conversation pretty
early on even if there are no
obvious clues so you drop clues to see
if the other person
it's like dating right it's not
intentional right but there is something
about their way of interacting there is
a kind of presence
that i know it seems like sort of
magical thinking the way i'm explaining
it but
somehow you end up talking about music
it might be like an
av person backstage when i'm giving a
talk somehow
in five or ten minutes we figure out
that the other is a deadhead
so i do think there's a way of
interacting that people might learn in
that community or maybe they take to
that community
but they also express it outside of that
community so they don't have to be
on tour with the band when they're
behaving you know as
their best deadhead self i don't think
this is unusual i mean as i said before
everybody seeks belonging it's a human
tribal
instinct it makes us feel safe and so
subconsciously or consciously
i think we're constantly giving out
signals to see if somebody is
of my tribe you know some people wear
iconography you know religious
iconography that gives away
some of your values and some of your
beliefs sometimes fashion plays that
role the point is is like in a modern
society we're constantly looking for
ways you wear a necklace
you know you don't look like a
stereotypical deadhead but you're giving
it away and if somebody catches your
necklace even if you forgot you're
wearing it that day
someone will come over to you and i'm
sure there's a way of introducing each
other
you'll make a point of creating
connection and i think that's normal in
society we're constantly looking to do
that
the question i have now is in this day
and age where
that kind of human interaction has been
very diminished
how do we find that sense of belonging
how do we create those connections
through a largely online world that
we're living in i mean most of us are
going to work online we're having
meetings online we're meeting people
online we're dating online
how do we establish and send those clues
out
i've been thinking a lot about this uh
especially
because i've had experiences recently
where i do run into a deadhead and
something very
sort of friendly happens and i think why
am i not doing that all the time
so recently i was driving i was annoyed
people had pulled out in front of me
and i had a traffic light and a guy the
guy in the car next to me and i was sort
of
ready to be honked at i could sort of
see out of the corner of my eye that he
was looking at me and i looked over
and he held up his hand like this and
what i'm doing
is i'm holding up my right hand and my
middle finger is down
and that might seem strange and he had a
smile on his face but what
what that meant was that he's a deadhead
because jerry garcia lost his middle
finger on his right hand
it was cut off by an axe as a child so
that meant i'm a deadhead and i was
suddenly
reminded that i'm a kind person and
that my feeling irritated in general at
that moment was completely and utterly
useless so
that generosity that sort of feeling of
kindness then extended to people way
beyond the guy in the car next to me who
was deadhead i have i have a sticker on
my car that's how he knew
right so he saw the sticker he showed me
the sign that he's a deadhead
and suddenly that is unlocked in me that
feeling those values
are unlocked in me it reminded you it
reminded you to live
exactly right but they were clenched
they were locked up they were behind
this wall
and that reminded me this is who you are
in your happiest moments and you know
when i talk to people
about what your authentic best self is
they're always trying to think of
their authentic best self at work and i
say no
no wrong i say take the last three four
years of your life
what is the best moment because i bet it
wasn't at work
but you were feeling deeply connected
with people you were feeling seen
you were seeing them and you also felt
you know confident you felt a sense of
agency but that wasn't the first thing
that you felt what you were feeling was
connected
and seen and seeing that's how i feel in
a dead show
that is my authentic best self now
somebody had told me
10 years ago at harvard business school
oh you know your authentic best self is
that person
at a dead show and you need to bring
that into the classroom i would have
thought that they were
you know they were you know yanking my
chain but that actually is exactly what
it is
that is my authentic best self so who i
am when i'm watching music
you know and hanging out with all of
these strangers you know dirty stadium
floor
that's the person i want to bring in
when i'm teaching students at harvard
business school
so i want to go back to my question so
in a digital world now in our online
remote world
how do we do we do that have we have we
lost that
ability that seems really important
i definitely don't think we've lost the
ability i do
and i'm not directly at answering your
question just yet but i'm talking
kind of about a tribe that i belong to
right and that that tribe reminds me
of who i am in my best moments of what
i'm capable of in terms of generosity
with other humans at the same time we
belong to tribes that are not bringing
out our best selves
and are not reminding us of how generous
we can be
so i'm sort of saying when i'm reminded
of this tribe
i become much more understanding and
compassionate but there are other tribes
that you know
i can be reminded of that make me less
compassionate here's what i think is
interesting
right which is and i had a long
conversation with dia khan about this
we seek belonging and when the
leadership of the tribe
when the other members of the tribe have
genuine generosity
in their heart to include you in the
tribe
then it'll bring out your best self but
when they invite you into the tribe for
selfish reasons
then it won't necessarily bring out your
best self so for example
al qaeda or isis have remarkable
recruiting outfits
where they make these disenfranchised
young people
feel loved and belonging and they're
available online at all hours of the day
but the thing is you don't even know
that you're talking to the same person
and they want you to join for their
political purposes they don't actually
care
about you right or in a business for
example
where you might be at the top performing
ex and you're recruited and showered
with money and praise because they just
want you to perform but if you stop
performing they fire you
the love that they gave you was
selfishly motivated right
and so the hard thing is for the tribe
member
for the community member sometimes it's
really hard for us to tell the
difference
because it feels really good to feel
included it feels really good to feel
told that we belong and a gang for
example you know right
and it's only until later that we
discovered that it was a farce that it
was a fraud
and so i think this intense human desire
to find belonging and find quote unquote
our people find our tribe
we are all susceptible to being duped i
agree
and that to your point it can bring out
the worst in us sometimes
right but if it's genuinely with love
and there's genuinely an altruism and a
desire to give
then your best self does come out
because that becomes the reason to for
you to invite somebody else into the
tribe
right right so one of the points that
you're bringing up is
some of these tribes are recruiting you
because they need you
to achieve some possibly sinister goal
although they don't see it as sinister
but no the tribes that do bring out the
friendliest or most generous selves
don't need you as an instrument they
enjoy enjoying the thing they love
with other people but they don't
necessarily need the other people
and they definitely don't need you
specifically they like you
because it brings out the best in them
and that makes them feel
good right so what are the things that
remind us that we are
together right that we do have a shared
goal that's that's good
and i don't know exactly what those
things are right now
because people feel so different from
each other
on very salient dimensions that it's
hard to get them to even pay attention
to the dimensions
that aren't in their twitter feed every
day all the time
that's an interesting point i would
argue that
the fundamentals are the same right but
they're harder to implement and actually
where
in the human interaction world
in the human interaction world a lot of
it is instinctive a lot of it is
uh non-verbal your specialty non-verbal
communication
and in the online world it has to be on
purpose
and it has to be verbal in other words
we just go back to the necklace you're
wearing you have a non-verbal piece of
communication hanging around your neck
you have a non-verbal piece of
communication stuck on your car
right bears or something
and so you forget that you're wearing
the jewelry you forget that you have a
sticker on your car and you're driving
around all day
people can see where you belong and so
they can immediately pick up on the
queue
and send a signal your way as well or or
just treat you differently
right and in the online world i think we
have to make
it takes more effort where we actually
have to say things even to the point of
being a little bit awkward to make these
things known
because the nonverbal communication and
you tell me you're the expert here
nonverbal communication in an online
world how does that even work
well i mean this is online and you and i
right now are looking at each other
or i could be looking at my own pictures
that's true
but we're also i mean nonverbal is also
you know vocal cues are also non-verbal
cues so you're talking really about
places where it's just
words and there's nothing else i mean
people's bios
tell you something about where they're
coming from so if you go back to the
yes i'm wearing it they call this a
steal your face around my neck and i
have one on the back of my car
why do i do that i think part of why i
do that is that i'm signaling to people
i'm kind i'm open to you assuming people
know what it means
right so that's the people who know what
it means but at least those people also
if they're having a bad day and they see
that sticker
it's going to open something up in them
so i am trying to let people know
so that one they are kind to me and two
it might unlock that kindness in them as
well people do that sometimes
even in things like twitter bios what
you want to be signaling to people
is i'm open to you but we are signaling
the opposite
so i go back to what i said before which
i think the fundamentals are the same so
for example
that subculture that community has to
have a sense of purpose or cause
it has to have a reason for being and it
has to have explicit values
and as my friend george flynn defines
culture which i love i love his
definition
he's a retired marine general he says
culture
equals values plus behavior right so you
have a strong culture when the values
are clearly articulated and the people
in that culture live those values
so let's say the people in that
community live those values
then it becomes a culture and if you
think about iconography we use
iconography as shorthand to tell people
what we believe or who we are where
we're from
and you think about some of the stickers
that people stick on their cars to tell
you something about themselves
harley-davidson stickers apple stickers
you know
i love my favorite is people who have a
dell or a pc that's given to them from
their office and they stick an apple
sticker over the computer
right just to let everybody know i
didn't choose this right
right but i've never seen anybody stick
a dell on a mac right
star wars i you know star wars
iconography is a big one
sort of nerd culture yeah and it's all
of these signals just to let you know
by the way i have a star wars i have a
star wars
license plate but it's really subtle and
only if you know
will you know why do you have that
because i love it right but you would
not let me just say because i love it
you know that that's not the only reason
why i have a steal your face sticker on
the back of my car
because i'm like you which is it's a
part of my self-identity
it's a culture that i like the people
and it's exactly the same as you
i in a subtle way like putting it out
there
that i'm a member of this culture and if
somebody catches it they'll know
and i just like that i like the nudge
and the wink i mean this is one of the
things about community
right i mean put it this way if you were
to go to a large event
a corporate event and everybody's
hanging out and you're sort of doing the
thing you do and like people come up and
talk and you talk to people
and you catch somebody across the hall
who doesn't look like anybody quote
unquote you would normally talk to
you know they might look stiff or you
know and yet you happen to notice they
have a
grateful dead symbol on their lapel or
around their neck
you're gonna make a beeline for that
person of course right and i think we do
that all the time we're such tribal
animals were so
highly attuned and sometimes we get it
wrong sometimes we embarrass ourselves
because we get the signals mixed up
oh i'm so sorry i thought i thought you
know because we're all so desperately
looking for a sense of community and
belonging especially
when we don't belong especially when we
feel like we're an outsider
right but i think there's something more
there
and it's that so barb frederickson has
this idea that we misunderstand the
concept of love
and by misunderstanding the concept of
love we're missing out on
moments of love that we could be
experiencing appreciating
acknowledging recognizing every single
day of our lives and she calls this
micro love
and the idea is that love is not just
exchanged between
romantic partners and parents and
children and best friends
it is exchanged in that little glance
between strangers
so i am addicted to micro love you know
i
live for those moments i love fiercely
too i mean i love my
husband and son and my friends fiercely
but those moments of micro love that
little exchange with the guy in the car
next to me
that just cracked my heart open and i
need my heart to be cracked open right
now
everybody does right so that little
glance that's why i have the sticker on
my car
that's why i wear this around my neck
because when i'm waiting in line for
coffee
and the person six feet ahead of me
who's annoyed that you know we have to
be six feet apart and wearing masks
turns around and sees that
i'm gonna see the smile in their eyes
and i'm gonna give them that same smile
back again
sorry um my emotions are so close to the
surface right now
that's what it's about we are missing
out on moments of love because we're
looking for this ridiculous sort of
hollywood
concept of love it's just one tiny part
of love
see this is what i'm talking about you
know it's this vulnerability
that you keep your emotions and that you
can make yourself cry
from talking about tiny acts of
generosity and tiny acts of kindness and
micro love
and it's not the set lists yeah it's
that the reason you sacrifice and people
leave their work and take days off and
take vacation days and spend their money
to be
around the grateful dead is because the
intense feelings of being around people
who give you that micro love
every moment of every day is
overwhelming and beautiful and you seek
it out and want it as much as you can
get it
that's right and if only it existed
everywhere in society you wouldn't have
to travel around the world
but you do that's that's right yeah so
the thing that i've learned from talking
to you today is that
community is this thing that we all
desperately want yeah
you know community is a place where we
find safety but
you want it to be safety based on shared
values and shared beliefs
not shared fear that's right the reality
is the way we fix this is very simple
which is we all get on the bus and
follow the grateful dead that's exactly
right
but we all have to get on together yeah
and in this day and age we have to get
on our own bus with masks we can't get
on the same bus that's exactly right
that's fine too
amy always a joy to see you
thank you you too simon thanks for
taking the time thanks
i hope you enjoyed this bit of optimism
if you'd like more
please subscribe wherever you like to
listen to podcasts
i hope you'll join me next time until
then
take care of yourself and take care of
each other